me compré zapatos nuevos y se los quería
mostrar a todos
se los compré a este señor
este señor se llama catalino y vive acá
en la estación rosario norte hace 20
años
acá está catalina dándome cuando me sus
zapatos
y se los compré para la charla porque
para mí es una ocasión muy especial
y quería estrenar zapatos
cuando estudiaba yo estudio publicidad
cuando estaban buenos aires- estudiando
en la facultad nos dieron un ejercicio
que consistía en salir a la calle y
cambiar algo para ver cómo la gente
reaccionaba
entonces lo que hice fue vestirme como
estoy vestido hoy y me fui al obelisco y
cuando los autos paraban en el semáforo
en lugar de pedirles dinero yo les daba
un peso
que compruebe con eso comprobé los
prejuicios que tiene la gente porque
apenas me veían acercarme al auto me
subían la ventana o miraban para
adelante pretendiendo que ahí no había
nadie que no había una persona y
realmente creaban también una situación
de incómoda para uno que duraba hasta el
siguiente semáforo y se volvía a sentir
incómodos e ignorando a otra persona
las mujeres por lo general ponían el
bolso atrás
el ejercicio fue un éxito y así fue que
conseguir trabajo en mi primera agencia
a gucci bachetti
después de eso pase a vega olmos ponce y
en el 2001 me escape del ruido
ensordecedor de las cacerolas yéndome a
londres con mil dólares una visa de
turista y sin hablar una sola palabra de
inglés sobrevivió un año trabajé lavando
platos y armado en drama andamios para
obras en construcción e instalando
equipos de refrigeración y aire
acondicionado volví de londres deportado
por trabajar ilegalmente por trabajar el
doble de las horas permitidas pero la
experiencia fue la mejor de mi vida
regresé a trabajar a trabajar en
publicidad durante dos años en una nueva
agencia hasta que recibí una oferta de
una agencia en nueva york'
y me fui sin pensarlo pero esta vez con
un departamento o pago frente al empire
state y un sueldo de 60 mil dólares al
año
una experiencia completamente diferente
pero que la podía valorar mucho después
de la experiencia de londres no
así fue que me puse de novio al poquito
tiempo de irnos a vivir juntos recibí un
llamado de una agencia en austin en
texas que me ofrecían trabajo le dije
mira acabo de mudarme con mi novia hace
un mes no no puedo aceptar ella tiene
trabajo y me dijo le damos trabajo a
ella también
bueno fuimos un fin de semana nos gustó
la ciudad nos mudamos llegamos un
domingo y el lunes nos enteramos que
ella estaba embarazada
nos casamos traje a mis padres de
argentina y nos casamos en puerto rico-
embarazados nos casamos embarazados pero
muy contentos
y en el 2009 nació elena que es el amor
de mi vida es a bbva que está ahí
cuando elena tenía un año y medio
recibe un llamado de mi hermano yo
estaba almorzando y que me dice que mis
padres habían tenido un accidente de
tránsito muy grave y sabía cómo estaban
sabía que estaban graves pero había sido
cerca de rafaela viniendo de santiago
del estero y no tenían ninguna noticia
sin saber absolutamente nada me tomó un
avión me espera un amigo en ezeiza y me
tierras a rafaela
y me encontré con esto me encontré con
mi papá en coma
una madre con todos los huesos quebrados
mi padre estuvo en coma durante 10 meses
hasta que falleció
y mi madre estuvo seis meses en cama con
seis operaciones
esta es la última vez que le apreté la
mano a mi padre porque al principio me
escuchaba y respondía y después nos
respondimos
y nada regresé a austin a trabajar tenía
que seguir trabajando y como a los 5
meses antes de que mi padre
se muera
tuve una discusión con mi esposa por la
mañana y me fui a el trabajo dando un
portazo
y al día siguiente recibí una demanda de
divorcio y me quedé en la calle
perdí mi hija perdí mi casa y con mis
padres en esa situación argentina me
quedé completamente solo y me fui a
vivir a la casa un amigo a dormir a un
sofá
en ese momento yo usaba instagram esta
aplicación de fotos como cualquier otro
sacándole fotos a un cielo un pajarito
lo que se me cruza
y un día me encontré con este señor
y pedí sacarle una foto y le dio un
dólar por la foto y me queda hablando
con él y me contó su historia
y de repente todos mis problemas
hicieron pequeñitos al lado de la
historia de este señor me sirvió para
valorar todas las cosas que tenía que no
eran pocas
yo estaba saludable mi hija estaba
saludable tenía un sofá para dormir es
un montón
a partir de ese día me enfoqué en hacer
retratos de gente de la calle encontré
en ellos
la familia que nos faltaba el apoyo que
me faltaba
sus historias me hicieron valorar todo
lo que tenía
y empecé a ganar seguidores
anal seguidores y cada vez siempre ponía
la foto de ellos y su nombre si la
historia era interesante contaba algo de
su historia
y en ellos encontré eso la familia la
familia que me faltaba hasta que un día
me encontré con este señor
este señor estuvimos hablando le saqué
la foto le pagué el dólar y antes de
irme este hombre me dice sabes lo único
que me gustaría hacer antes de morirme y
bueno me dice la oktoberfest
oktoberfest dice no sí porque me contó
que era descendiente de alemanes que
siempre había soñado con ir a alemania
nos reímos los dos y murcia el trabajo y
en el camino al trabajo y yo en ese
momento tenía como cinco mil seguidores
en instagram
en el camino al trabajo se me ocurrió la
idea si cada seguidor que yo tengo me
dona un dólar que es lo mismo que yo les
pagaba yo me puedo llevar a este tipo
alemania y puedo hacer un libro de la
experiencia y empecé a soñar con eso
y sin pensarlo mucho puse la foto de él
con el titular quien quiere llevar a
este tipo oktoberfest saqué una cuenta
de paypal arme un site llamado one
dollar dreams y de repente una señora de
japón me mandó 100 dólares y un tipo de
sudáfrica me mandó cinco y uno de eeuu
me mandó dos y me di cuenta que había
una idea importante que había una idea
grande
mi padre fallece en ese momento y tengo
un amigo que vive en colombia y me dice
por tienda te venís te quedas en casa
olvídate un poco de los problemas me
saque el pasaje con misas y me fui a
colombia en colombia hice fotos en
colombia mientras mi amigo trabajaba yo
iba a la calle y hacía fotos y escuchaba
historias y anotaban hombres
y me di cuenta de la realidad tan
diferente a la realidad de eeuu como
cualquier país de latinoamérica la
realidad de la gente de la calle acá es
muy diferente
me encontré con este chico este chico me
pidió dinero para comprar zapatillas y
como sabía que de repente iba a estar el
dinero otra cosa fui con él y le compré
las zapatillas acá se está probando las
zapatillas y acá está contento con sus
zapatillas nuevas
seguí sacando fotos hasta que me
encontré ha sido la numeración de en
colombia'
esto es y es parte del paisaje no nos
damos cuenta fíjense como la gente pasa
caminando no existe es un tacho de
basura más
miren por donde pasa ese colectivo
se dice hasta que me encontré con este
chico este chico se llama alex alex
venía de un pueblo del interior y había
llegado a medellín a tocar la guitarra
en los colectivos y era adicto al paco
y fue a comprar droga y cuando salía de
comprar droga lo cortaron una navaja y
le robaron la droga la guitarra las
zapatillas todos llevaba tres días en la
calle con los pies hinchados no podía
caminar y en la mano tenía un papel de
un centro de rehabilitación
y me contó que había ido a pedirle a la
porque no aguantaba más que ha ido a
pedirle a la policía si lo llevaba al
centro y la policía no le había dado
pelota
entonces le pregunté si realmente quería
quería rehabilitarse me dijo que era lo
que más quería que no aguantaba más y
tomamos un taxi lo llevamos centro de
rehabilitación me convertí en su padrino
y álex estuvo en centro por 10 meses
hasta que salió y consiguió trabajo
volvió a austin y me mandaron de la
agencia a filmar un comercial a méxico
es el comercial y después me quedé el
fin de semana un fin de semana largo en
la casa de un amigo hice fotos en mexico
la primera foto que saque se estrene m
este nene estaba pintado del payaso
pidiendo en el semáforo y sus papás
estaban en la esquina tomando vino y
esperando que trabaje
esto es méxico muchos niños en la calle
y seguir juntando historias y contando
todo en vivo a través de a través de
instagram
y ganando seguidores y la gente dándome
aliento
lo que me hizo lo que me hizo muy bien
para mi historia nuevamente historia
personal y también para el hecho de que
siempre trabajé en publicidad me gustan
las ideas soy un apasionado de las ideas
y de resolver problemas pero no soy un
apasionado de vender chiquitos que
tienen
monsanto me entienden entonces encontré
en este proyecto algo que realmente me
llenó la vida
tuve que ir a editar el comercial de los
ángeles entonces tenía que editarlo
desde un miércoles a un jueves
y me quede el fin de semana en la calle
no tenía dinero me quedé en la calle
hice fotos en los ángeles compartiendo
la experiencia en vivo a través de
instagram
saque fotos en los ángeles y luego llegó
nos tiene lo encontré a este señor este
señor estaba sin trabajo era chef
lo llevé a un negocio de le completo el
equipo del chef un set de cuchillos y
fui con él a diferentes restaurantes y
les ofrecí publicidad los restaurantes a
través de mis redes sociales para que
considera trabajo y consiguió trabajo en
el primer lugar que fuimos
me invitaron a dar una conferencia a
uruguay me fui diez días antes hice
fotos en uruguay y para la conferencia
de uruguay lo que hice fue agarrar un
chico de la calle que esté sebastián y
dice algo al revés de lo que hice hoy
acá lo vestí a sebastián de publicista y
sebastián estuvo con una habitación de
hotel y ropa nueva mezclado entre la
gente durante el festival y al momento y
ahí comprobé que también por el aspecto
de una persona también pasa al revés y
estaba bien vestido no importa si sos
alcohólico joven la gente te va a
respetar
me fui a españa algo un amigo también
siempre quedando buenísimo tener amigos
por todo el mundo y se hice fotos en
madrid durante 10 días y una periodista
a través de instagram y me ofreció esa
en una entrevista después de la
entrevista me ofreció su departamento en
barcelona y me dio barcelona y estuve 10
días en barcelona haciendo fotos en
barcelona después de españa todos estos
españa muchas fotos en españa me
invitaron al salvador en el salvador
hice lo mismo fui diez días antes hice
fotos en el salvador pero para el
salvador lo que hice fue me puse en
contacto con la madre de un asistente a
la conferencia sin que el asistente
supiera y la disfrazamos a la mamá de
homeless y hice fotos de su mamá vestida
de homeless entonces cuando estaba
mostrando las fotos como estoy mostrando
ahora de repente apareció la mamá de
este chico
qué es esta
nadie sabía nada él solo pero para él ya
no vio a la gente ingente de la misma
manera porque porque cuando esa persona
es alguien querido la perspectiva cambia
cuando es alguien que al que le tenemos
cariño y estas personas que viven en la
calle son hermanos de alguien hijos de
alguien madres de alguien todos
después regresé austin y tenía ganas de
hacer un estudio más grande de eeuu
porque había hecho solamente austin y
los ángeles no tenía dinero y de
cualquier manera como todas las otras
veces agarré el auto y me fui con mil
dólares en la misma cantidad de dinero
que me había llevado a londres y agarré
la ruta estuve dos meses recorrí diez
mil millas
durante dos meses hice las vegas los
ángeles san francisco san francisco
denver san luis y detroit new york
washington atlanta miami key west new
orleans y regresé a austin ahora la
gente la gente me abrió las puertas de
sus casas me dieron dinero me dieron
comida y mucho pero mucho aliento en san
francisco
invite a un homeless
a un chico estaba en la calle a venir
conmigo y viajamos juntos durante un mes
y lo dejé en key west el viaje fue un
éxito y por último les quiero hablar de
la suerte
la importancia porque muchas veces
discriminamos a la gente
simplemente por la apariencia pero no
tenemos en cuenta que es todo suerte
ustedes tienen mucha suerte de estar hoy
acá escuchando esta charla y bien
vestidos
la suerte es un factor fundamental no
solamente en las cosas que a uno le toca
sino en las decisiones que uno toma
porque todo eso determina lo que uno va
a decidir además más adelante por
ejemplo es este gorro que yo tengo es el
resultado de un padre alcohólico y
abusador este gorro este saco este saco
es mi hermano que me dio pegamento
cuando yo tenía 7 años eso es este saco
estos zapatos que tengo puestos son el
no haber ido a la escuela los zapatos de
catalino que duelen duelen mucho esta
camisa que tengo puesta
es
lo que me pegaron en el barrio
las amistades las buenas amistades
y finalmente estos pantalones estos
pantalones son mi mamá que trabajaba de
[ __ ] y no estaba nunca en casa
somos todos iguales como ustedes pueden
ver diferencias más diferencias menos yo
siempre trato de estar agradecido por lo
que tengo y no preocupado por lo que me
falta
este
este calzón este calzón
es haber ido haber nacido en el
sanatorio británico con médico de
primera línea
esta camiseta esta camiseta no ha venido
al colegio maristas desde el jardín
hasta el secundario por favor seguimos
hablando no creo
planchada por mi mamá la noche me la
plancha mi mamá que está por acá
este pantalón es el haberme equivocado
de carrera tres veces y mis viejos que
me bancaron hasta que encontré lo que me
gustaba
y finalmente estos son mis zapatos los
que he visto todos los días
y que representan el esfuerzo de mi mamá
que con 74 años sigue trabajando para
que un [ __ ] divorcio no me deja en la
calle estos son mis zapatos y les
agradezco a todos por haberse los
puestos por 18 minutos gracias mamá
gracias a todos